time to rummage under your bed and dust
off your disks because for more xbox 360
games are now playable on Xbox one I'm
Lucy and welcome to your I'll just hang
on to this one in case I want to play it
again GameSpot news update
Microsoft's Major Nelson announced the
new arrivals on Twitter
they include call of duty world at war
ii for every extend extra extreme and
clever meant experiment and fun town
mahjong world wall is not the first xbox
360 Call of Duty title now playable on
Xbox one as it joins call of duty two
three and black ops the major also
confirmed that all backwards-compatible
Call of Duty titles can now be purchased
directly from the Xbox one before this
some needed to be purchased through Xbox
comm if you own any of the four games
added to the backwards compatibility
catalog they should show up
automatically in your Xbox one game
library alternatively you can buy them
from your Xbox one console or from
xbox.com call of duty world at war is
$20 and all the others cost $10 each
there are now more than 250 Xbox 360
games playable on Xbox one through
backwards compatibility but which games
would you like to see let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on Xbox one make sure you keep it
GameSpot